Amazon is extending its reach with a big
move into the major appliance Market the
online retail giant will begin selling
Kenmore brand appliances from Sears
they'll be equipped with Amazon's
virtual assistant Alexa so Kenmore smart
air conditioners and refrigerators will
respond to voice commands Sears Holdings
has faced losses for seven years its
chairman and CEO says the launch of
Kenmore products on amazon.com will
significantly expand the distribution
and availability of the kinmore brand
brand in the US Dereck Thompson is a
senior editor at the Atlantic Derek good
morning great to have you here so uh
earlier this year said there there's a
substantial doubt that the company can
remain in business did Christmas come
early with Amazon swooping in for seers
so I actually want to start with a short
story uh it's a short story about a
retail upstart uh that realizes that it
can make its hay by selling stuff to
people who just sit on their couches and
mail that stuff to them so the stuff can
reach their homes this mail order
company essentially Bec becomes a
logistics giant it even moves into the
brick and mortar business becomes the
retail company of its time I'm talking
about Sears robu of the turn of the 20th
century or Amazon the turn of the 21st
century the answer is both in many ways
Amazon is the new Sears and so it is
sort of historically fitting that it is
now turning out to bail out its
historical predecessor I do not think
that this saves Sears but this is one of
the more favorable terms of surrender I
could imagine it's amazing how new it is
how it's a it's it's an old story that
we' heard before well it's the front
page of the Wall Street Journal too
because as they say it will jolt the
appliance industry in some ways it's an
interesting marriage right exactly you
know Amazon is such a fascinating
company maybe the most fascinating
company in America right now because
when it enters a market it's like this
deflationary bomb is set off and every
other company in that industry loses
value we've seen it now with with
appliances that it gets into uh Kenmore
it gets into air conditioning and
refrigerators and other people that make
air conditioners refrigerator their
value Falls we saw this with Whole Foods
it gets into the grocery market and
other grocery uh chains find their value
is declining so people are so afraid of
Amazon right now and I use the word
marrying because marrying of the
technology meaning the voice command
Alexa into these appliances how would
that work yeah it's interesting so you
right now I think they're imagining
these Kenmore appliances would work so
that you're sitting on your couch and
you can say I'd like it to be 67° and
the air conditioning turns to 67° I
don't think I'm going to go out and say
that this is the
the remot contrology EXs you can button
it do to muchy to up and the down button
two times to go from 69 to 67 um so I
don't think this is quite revolutionary
but if if it helps them sell some
products then I suppose it's good Jeff
basos really is a Visionary what is he
looking for and what does he see in
companies ranging from The Washington
Post to Whole Foods now to Sears that
maybe other companies don't necessarily
see world
Dom the EXA same thing well I guess we
can all sing in unison world domination
I think he's looking at everything and
he wants to be in everything and once
again not to play a story in but this is
the same Playbook that we saw with Sears
Sears came out with a Discover Card
Sears came out with allate in order to
sell insurance along with its car parts
to Consumers this is the same idea it's
to create a life bundle around its
consumers so if you want to sit in the
couch order stuff watch television buy
your groceries all from Amazon they will
allow you to do it well Kenmore makes
great applian say I still think Sears is
a great American company so I hope this
is a beneficial partnership yeah me too
thanks Derek to see you